[Música]
hola bienvenidos a migrantes el programa
semanal de france 24 sobre el éxodo los
saluda juliet riaño
[Música]
el título 42 seguirá vigente la medida
que el gobierno del presidente
estadounidense joe biden esperaba
cancelar este 23 de mayo continuará
implementándose después de que
administraciones estatales republicanas
demandarán su fin y mientras en los
tribunales se define la continuidad de
la norma en la frontera sur de eeuu
miles tendrán que seguir esperando para
presentar sus solicitudes de refugio
andrés granadillo nos amplía en el
siguiente informe el título 42 seguirá
vigente hasta nuevo aviso un juez de
luisiana frenó los planes de washington
de levantar la medida este 23 de mayo la
política que entró en vigor en el
gobierno de donald trump faculta a los
agentes federales de la frontera con
mexico para devolver a los migrantes sin
posibilidad de tramitar solicitudes de
asilo mientras en ciudades fronterizas
de ciudad juárez y tijuana en el norte
de méxico esperan impacientes a que se
levante la medida
había mucha expectativa porque la
administración de bailén se había
comprometido a eliminar el título 42 el
23 de mayo pero eso se vio frenado en
una corte federal y pues lo más probable
es que no se va a eliminar el título 42
este lunes provenientes de cuba colombia
nicaragua venezuela y otras
nacionalidades de américa latina' cruzan
el río bravo con esperanza de llegar a
territorio estadounidense
seguiré el anterior por su familia
el título 42 se puso en marcha en marzo
de 2020 al inicio de la pandemia con el
propósito de frenar el avance del cob y
19 desde entonces más de un millón de
inmigrantes detenidos en la frontera han
sido expulsados rápidamente a méxico u
otros países en virtud de la orden a
menudo a las pocas horas de ser
capturados en abrir los centros de
control de enfermedades de eeuu dijeron
que ya no era necesario el título 42
para luchar contra el convoy 19 debido a
la disponibilidad de vacunas pero los
estados de arizona luisiana misurí y
otros todos con fiscales generales
republicanos han demandado para evitar
que la administración baiden terminará
con la política
mientras badén ha recibido críticas de
naciones unidas- de 10 miembros de su
propio partido por no actuar con rapidez
rumbo a una esperada política más humana
con los viajeros indocumentados
y es que no es el primer revés para el
gobierno estadounidense en su intento
por cumplir con una de sus principales
promesas de campaña baile no ha podido
sacar adelante sus iniciativas sobre
migración y los hechos demuestran que en
esta administración miles han sido
devueltos gracias a políticas del
anterior gobierno republicano hablamos
al respecto con eunice rendón
coordinadora de agenda migrante y red
viral
es importante ver como al gobierno de
bailén una y otra vez los jueces
federales y la suprema corte pues le ha
cambiado el plan primero pasó con el
programa de permanece en mexico que él
también prometió durante la campaña que
le va a terminar lo terminó durante los
primeros meses de su gobierno sin
embargo derivado de una serie de
demandas casi siempre encabezada por
gobiernos republicanos principalmente
por el gobernador abbott de texas bueno
esto llegó hasta la suprema corte y la
suprema corte hace cuatro meses le
obligó al gobierno de baena a reinstalar
este programa que lo que hace es que los
solicitantes de refugio en eeuu tengan
que esperar del lado mexicano eso es un
ejemplo que hoy vuelve a hacer este creo
que que viene al caso con el fallo que
da este juez y lo que podemos esperar es
que los procesos sigan siendo muy lentos
que siga implementando se esta
deportación expedita a través del título
42 repito más de un millón y medio de
personas principalmente digamos en la
época de bailén aunque fue un programa
iniciado by the end es el que más ha
utilizado el título 42 y regresado a
partir de marzo del año pasado pues más
de este millón y medio de personas sin
un aliado en la región eeuu no podría
avanzar en políticas como el título 42
cuál es el papel de méxico eunice rendón
nos explica
méxico pues no está preparado lo hemos
visto una y otra vez en los puntos
fronterizos
repito no solamente es el título 42 sino
que eeuu está echando mano de mexico
para deportar a todos los que quieren
título 42 pero también para el programa
de permanece en mexico que es que los
solicitantes de refugio en eeuu tienen
que esperar del lado mexicano y
desafortunadamente también estos puntos
fronterizos coinciden los de título 42
con permanecen méxico lo que hace que
haya pues un mayor número de migrantes
desordenados en la frontera del lado
mexicano y además coinciden con que son
muchos de estos puntos los lugares o
ciudades de mayor inseguridad también en
méxico entonces pues eso como ya se ha
demostrado y se ha escrito por ejemplo
human right watch sacó un algunos
reportes muy interesantes la propia
comisión nacional de derechos humanos en
méxico ha sacado reportes importantes
con respecto a estos programas y a la
violación que se ha dado del debido
proceso y de los derechos de los
migrantes no yo creo que méxico tiene un
reto muy importante y desafortunadamente
méxico ha tenido colocó una actitud este
que se contrapone porque me el título 42
ni el programa permanece en méxico
pudieran ser posibles de no ser porque
hay un acuerdo con el gobierno mexicano
porque ambos programas utilizan el
territorio mexicano entonces no sólo son
decisiones del gobierno estadounidense
sino que también implican la política
migrante mexicana el gobierno demócrata
informó que apelará el fallo que bloqueó
el fin del título 42 y mientras tanto
miles de personas en condiciones
humanitarias difíciles se preguntan qué
hacer en la frontera sur de estados
unidos hasta aquí inmigrantes de france
24 los invitamos a comentar en nuestras
redes sociales con el hashtag migrantes
f24 sigan con más información en france
24 y france 24 puntocom
[Música]